okay good so I'm gonna start sharing my
screen and someone let me know if that's
visible oh yeah we can hear anybody cool
so hello from Valencia Spain I'm Owen
the CEO of Kai so the COO I suppose like
yeah everybody is having her planes one
of the cool things is that I'm pretty
happy to be able to talk from this far
away and it's all being more here now
and I think it's pretty warm and Berlin
- is it so the the topic of my talk is
that everybody here companies and
research groups should have formalized
or systematic way to share and allow
others to discover their data insights
I'll tell you a bit about myself and
then how and why I came up with this and
like currently my company is trying to
solve this problem so like I used to
work in building quantum computers and
modeling quantum systems and I was
working big research groups and the
issue was that the sharing of analysis
reports was very very messy and I was he
that's only getting worse no because
everybody's forswore from home so for
example I was in a team of like 20
people making semiconductor chips we
would create them so they were like
little prototype quantum computing
computers so we would make them we would
test them and then we would analyze the
data and simulate the chips and then try
to you know make them better the problem
was that we had no central system for
like all of us collaborating and sharing
the results and the results were like
typically presented we would a lot like
a lot of us would do the analysis and
Jupiter notebooks but then that we had
no central place to post those they were
just like sitting in a shared Drive
unlabeled some people would do their
analysis and or and then save it to a
PowerPoint and then that would just like
get presented once to the boss and I get
dumped in a folder and no one would ever
see it again and it's called lo the
trouble for us so even got really
frustrated and I said
a solution which is which is what I'm
going to talk about but also just I'm
gonna make the argument in general for a
kind of a systematic way for sharing
results so what I'm going to cover today
really is the difference between
discovery and sharing of results that
other people make so we all do sharing
that's like one-to-one but then actually
discovery allowing other people to
discover your work is very very
important and then I'm going to go
through like two really common like
archetype are typical examples of
companies our research teams and how
it's still having a centralized place
for results is really helpful so I'll go
through a typical say startup or
organization that has data scientists
but also has multiple different types of
stakeholders like marketing teams
executive teams sales teams and then
I'll go to an example of like a deep
tech company or like a research group
who are where say everybody in the team
is technical but there's still a lot of
value to be gained from you know sharing
your results in a kind of a formalized
way and then I'll go through kind of my
way of setting up our team or a team
that I've worked on for kind of rep
reducible Python Jupiter data science
projects where you know we crunch the
numbers in Python typically within a Jew
per node Jupiter notebook it doesn't
have to be but then you know setting the
project up in such a way that it's
version controlled the project is
represent the project so that it's very
very shareable and then everyone else in
your team can kind of discover it
so generally data Stein's reporting is a
mess the difference then a key a key
inside I want to get true here is a
difference between discovering sharing
so all of us are everyday sharing you
know you you look at your colleague
screen and they can show you their
results you can make presentations to
people in groups you can email your boss
your colleague PNG or an image to make
an argument to them you can talk on
slack you can physically talk over
coffee so that's very like one-to-one
sharing right and what happens then is
that like kind of data insights get kind
of
siloed within groups because of you know
I'll share with you you shall be your
friend but then maybe the chain stops
there and then someone else who we don't
even know could benefit from the data
inside it just doesn't reach them so
that's why discovery is really important
where you have one place for all of the
results that people you haven't even
thought of using your results can
discover it and use it in their work so
discovery is like a key factor that I
think a lot of groups and companies
don't get and it's super super important
so like just to give you general what
kind of view like the kind of systems
I'm arguing that people should be
setting up it's tough like notion like
confluence Airbnb have created knowledge
repo which is a places to post you for
notebooks people do this in general and
github as well I don't think it's a
great solution a lot of people like
research booking universities ruin
internal WordPress as a kind of a way of
sharing results throughout the team and
as like a ton more rights they're gonna
turn blogs whatever so here like I'm
gonna go through the two examples of
like the different types of companies so
let's think of a company called Acme
it's just a general online SAS company
that charges per see like per person on
a team that's using the product and the
CEO James just wants to like find out
more like you're gonna get a better
overview of the customers so he asked
Sarah the data scientist to make a
report of user behavior and what Sarah
comes look what is this she starts
working in Jupiter what I'm showing you
now is a Jupiter notebook hosted on PI
so sometimes I don't work and get up so
this is like I can show you the code
here is that visible I getting a lot of
zoom things coming up in which game I'm
not sure if you're seeing that so what's
happened here is you know Sarah has
taken company data that was on MongoDB
in a database it was on mixed panel I
was on google analytics and she's
thought that I would like various key
piece of data about how the customers
are using the platform so like a really
quick example a quick piece of knowledge
to learn is like what's the distribution
of team size this is just a simple
histogram you take all of like the
team's and you take the size and you
make it a simple
to Graham and it shows you like kind of
like half of a Gaussian average team
size is somewhere about 200 or more but
like a lot of T small teams less than
200 some teams over 500 and that's
producing - no and then what she does is
she like publishes she studies the
number of articles to say if it's good
or but that would be like the number of
repos and if it's confluence number of
articles it's notional number of
articles the number of articles are post
per team versus the size of teams and
watch you kind of discovers dennis is
actually like a super linear dependence
on number of post by the team size so
what happens is like teams of 400 or
more use the system proportionally more
than smaller teams so it's some kind of
cumulative or quadratic or exponential
dependence and it's the same then for
like the number of comments made and
then like we could figure out why is
this because like as teams scale up is
it just more connections between people
that they chat more you know like I'm
not sure but I'd say the number of slack
messages don't like her group does not
scale linearly with the number of group
members right it probably scales super
linearly
she's also plotted out like the paid
views or like the logins per team and
the distribution is like say events on
Mixpanel
right so this is a fairly simple kind of
piece of analysis that a company would
typically want to know about their
customers behavior and so now let's look
at the case where Sarah like does this
job and she emails it to the CEO right
this is when they don't have a
centralized system the CEO then reads
the report and that's it so what happens
is like Sarah might tell a few people
the CEO might tell a few people tell the
board tell the investors with the
insight that there's a superlinear
like a both linear dependence on like
product usage on the number on the size
of the team that doesn't actually get
widely shared within the company because
there's no there's no discovery of this
result within the company so then we can
like think of the case where Acme then
the site set up a central hub well maybe
they've been forced to set up a central
hub for sharing stuff now we
the coronavirus everybody's working from
home they've decided to set up a central
system and we can look at what happens
then so Sarah posts the report on the
central knowledge of on their notion on
their air B&B knowledge repo on sake ISO
for example and then what will happen
right so everybody in the company can
see it so then Mary from the product
team reads it right she didn't like to
think she was going to see this Sarah
didn't think of Mary but Mary discovers
a number on the knowledge hub and she
reads it and she says oh god this is
really interesting that there's a super
linear dependence on usage to team size
right so then she's able to like kind of
think about deep diving so she's on the
product engineering team
she's now because it's been posted the
arc had been posted everybody on the
team she's seen it and she can now think
of like her team's goal and she can deep
dive into why this super linear
dependencies right maybe she'll see it
is because of the number of connections
between people on the team maybe it's a
political issue in companies the larger
the company is the more likely say a VP
of engineering or an executive will be
pushing product usage within the company
and maybe so maybe there's like a
cultural political reason for the
product getting used more by larger
companies right so this like inside is
clearly very valuable to MIT to Mary and
her product engineering team we could
also see that Patrick for marketing and
sales reads it and if the company is
charging per seat then it's extremely
interesting to them because he'll have a
fixed marketing or sales budget and now
what you can do is focus in on larger
team lead sizes right so you can take
all these leads and start focusing on on
the larger teams or the potential to be
larger because they make proportionally
more money from those kind of teens
right so then clearly now that they're
sharing in a kind of a systematic way
this is clearly relevant in a relevant
insight for Patrick then say Barbara
from the infrastructure team maybe the
cost of providing the service is not
linear with or is not flat right it's
not like hosting a blog maybe there's
something else to it and seaberry gets
worried that you know providing the
service to larger customers
it's just much more expensive and they
have to have to figure that out they
have to make your systems more scalable
or maybe they want to get more smaller
customers right so that's like an
example of just a typical company and
how moving from it like you're having no
system for curating and having
discoverable like a central place for
results like notebooks or lab notebooks
or whatever to to moving to a central
hub and then like how the productivity
can get driven within the company and
now I'll tell you maybe some people here
like working in research groups or in
like deep research companies where say
the difference being like a research
team and like a kind of a general team
is that and a research team everybody
might be technical right but here I'll
show you how
like in my experience for having worked
in a few like semiconductor research
teams and like photonics research teams
that the lack of a central place to
share results caused us a lot of
frustration we really would have done
better if we had if we had a central
system for example the lack of sharing
of say Jupiter notebooks that we were
all working on stopped us from
developing on top of other people's work
so for example I use my I was in am when
I was on the semiconductor team we used
to look we have to make these chips then
we test them so what we would do is we'd
shine lasers through them and we were
trying to make basically computer chips
using photons instead of electricity
instead of electrons and so we shine
lasers through them we would try to
exercise like quantum static states in
the chips we would take the data we'd
always be looking at light spectra right
so like a common thing we had to do was
to like 50 OC UNS really really well and
maybe like an automatic automated
fashion
- just like tons of spectrum that we
were measuring everybody in my team
about 20 people across ten labs we were
all measuring spectrum we were all
fitting gaussians all the time and we
needed like sophisticated analysis like
a proper error management all this kind
of stuff you wanted to be like you
wanted to make sure that for example
like it could automatically pick out
gaussians from
noisy data so you're not spending your
whole day just dragging a slider to give
Gaussian and 20 of us had a different
way of doing it so a few of us used you
for notebooks and Python some of us were
using or some people were in Excel and
we had no like central place that we
could post like I could post my notebook
and then the person in the lab next to
me could come along and reuse that
notebook and then improve it so think of
like two teams one of which everybody's
building on everybody else's work all
the time and then after five years they
just got like a beautiful like system in
their lab for you know analyzing data
because proper error management it's
fully automated it runs really fast you
don't need to be doing any manual data
prep and then think of a team that
doesn't have this right they don't have
the central place for sharing the work
they just stay as they are you know
they're all doing the work alone and
then another horrible thing happened
which is that because everybody in my
team would like keep their notebooks to
themselves or their insights in a way to
themselves
we had a guy leave the team and I wanted
to continue his project he had kind of
an interesting chip design that I wanted
to integrate into my II I was making
like a hybrid chip system like literally
glued chips together we wanted to use
some of his chips and he left he left
the team and I could not recreate his
work and we had to abandon the project
because we were on a network drive I
could see his data I could see his
notebooks I could see his PowerPoint
presentations but they were all like meh
stuff you know he'd never like curated
or set them up to be pushed to a central
place for everybody to read so I was
just like his own folder which was an
absolute mess even like emailing him
that was a thing so it doesn't even
apply when someone reads leaves the team
it also placed yourself from like a year
ago so like I ran this guy and I was
like hey man I need to get this project
going can you help me I've got all of
these folders can you tell me what's in
here and he's like I don't know I did
that a year ago I can't remember because
I didn't you know put it in a place that
we could all read from I didn't prep it
in a way first all to read so we had to
abandon the project mister
for your project making semiconductor
chips that's like a lot of money wasted
and then another thing so I was I was
later on working on a project where we
were in Ireland then in Cambridge in the
UK and we were making like automate
automated optical water sensors so we
would have a microfluidic chip like a
little glass chip with a lot of tiny
little pipe untrue and we would put
water to it and we would contaminate
some of the water with e.coli or
different bacteria we would shine a
laser at it and depending then on the
spectrum that came back you could tell
if there was or wasn't ecoli in the
water right so I used to do the laser
shooting and the data analysis and but
we had a PI in charge of the project we
had the person who would like set up the
e.coli concentrations in the water and
we had the people making the microphone
eat chips and I used to like work on get
up and I would just like show them my
notebooks and get up and expect him to
read it and I realized that you know
people can be on a technical team with
you and they they can write code they
understand analysis they understand the
entire project they might not be
technical in the same way as you so
Mikey I was like Anna not on github I'm
not gonna sign up to github I work the
way I work um the biologists and the
team were like look man I just want to
see the results of the of the experiment
I don't want to be reading your code I
don't want to be reading your methods
right so often like when you have a
notebook it's much more relevant to the
other people on your team when you're
sharing the results and like the
discussion of the analysis with them and
showing them your like mathematical
methods right so those are like some
reasons there's like when you have a
central place for your if you're like in
a deep tech or a research team those are
some reasons why setting up a central
place for sharing your your data
analysis is really really useful because
reuse of work goes up your full
transparency into what everyone else is
working on you don't have issues with
someone leaving the team and you can't
figure out their work you don't have
issues with forgetting your own work
from a year ago and you got to remember
then that people are always not
technical in the same way you have
different stakeholders with slightly
different positions even on technical
teams
so those are like the two I hope they're
I've convinced you like why having a
central system or some central way to
share your kind of data based project
reports is useful across say two types
of organizations like a common company a
general company with multiple types of
stakeholders and then also like the
technical teams where everybody's
probably technical but they might not be
unchecking the same way and this is kind
of what I came up with across the teams
I worked on like a fairly
straightforward way to share like data
analysis projects when you're working in
Python so one is that I'm actually
showing you like live here as well so
one is that you your data narrative goes
in a Jupiter notebook here I've got a
really quick example project which is
just you know connecting to
connecting to an example MongoDB
database for I'm plotting some of the
stuff to decide it right what I always
do is you put the data story in the
jupiter notebook and then what you do is
you used to read me use the readme for
install instructions right so that means
that if someone comes across the github
project they open up the readme and they
read me is where the installation
instruction goes so like how to set up
the project you install anaconda you
install condoms all Jupiter you set
least active then you all you always
have to give them instructions about how
to get access to the data right so in
this case it's just like getting access
to a [ __ ] connection URL it can also be
you know getting the security team to
hand you a hard drive they can also be
you know Jenny from data analysis
setting you up on the Mitch panel
account you always have to put in your
instructions there for how to get access
to the data and then like that the other
thing that is always use Conda for like
you can use docker I'm sure people here
are familiar like how to use Honda and
darker but just always do it I've worked
on so much teams where people would they
were just like open a notebook bring in
a file plot the file
how'd the graph take the graph email to
someone right and that is that like
those generate an insight for a day but
a long term it's effectively useless
because nobody else can come along and
reuse the project nobody else can come
along and be able to tell what the
insights gained were from the project in
a systematic way so like always have the
data story in Jupiter have a really for
the install instructions use Conda and
an environment on llamó or docker then
make sure you push to get up like just
like you have to I've been on loads of
teams where people would not version
control I probably don't have to explain
to people on this call but there's a
enough teams activity don't version
control or they version get on a really
messy way so you just have like a load
of git projects at one file in them
there's no readme there's no
organization and so then the last thing
I would suggest is
if you want to share it there is there's
tons out there where you can like take
your report you can write an article in
notion and you can link to this github
repository so you've got your like
insights in the notion article you've
got the link into the git repository you
can set up Airbnb is knowledge repo
where you can upload your notebooks
generally speaking looking at notebooks
on github has become redundant because
it just doesn't work like a lot and then
the thing that we made basically is
kaizo where you can post a lot of your
team's notebooks into one place and they
just look like blog posts you can you
can set up connections to get up so i've
logged in to get up in from my post of
account i can just search for the
project there and i can bring it into
COI so oh one one thing I forgot to
mention is I always add like a closet at
llamo or it can be another kind of file
metadata somewhere with like the title
and description and tags for your
project I'm quite sure then what we do
is we import the project we take a
closer that llamo it becomes the title
the description and the tags and then
you can have a look and then what's
happened is you sign up your whole team
to play so and now everybody in your
team can read this analysis it's not
just limited to the check the members of
the team like it will be on github you
don't have to spend time writing stories
into notion you can kind of do literate
programming where you know you tell the
story about the data in your group
notebook as you're creating the story
essentially and then like obviously
there's like links to github you can
view the code on PI so there's also like
you what a lot of people do is I showed
you an example there where there's just
like one data project in a repository so
this repo here it's like one data
project what a lot of people do is
because there's so much library use
reuse across projects what they do is
they'll have like one repository where
there's like a common data extractor
file I'm so say it's like connecting to
your data sources and then like many
different data analysis projects within
the repository you can also import them
and then just come up is different for
posts on quite so and all this
free you know it's free to get started
spraying 40 for smaller teams so give it
a go if you find it useful so yeah so
that's like you know how you can share
their Python data science projects data
story goes in the Jupiter notebook
always always have a readme with install
instructions always use some kind of rep
reducible representation like Conda or
darker push it to get up and make sure
you tell your story somewhere and you'll
see a lot of benefits so what we did
what I covered in this talk and I always
convinced you to set up some kind of
central system for analysis and results
sharing discovery is a lot better than
sharing don't you know do one-to-one
sharing of emailing of talks and stuff
make sure you have a central place that
everybody can have a look and learn from
what you're working on you never know
what you're gonna find it's kind of like
you know you've heard the phrase a death
by a thousand cuts this is the exact
opposite it's like huge productivity
benefits from like a lot of small
improvements that you get when you just
have full visibility onto like what
everybody else is doing we went through
two types of companies hopefully what
like one of these use cases covers you
which is like you're a general startup
they get a lot of benefit from everybody
seeing the results those different
stakeholders can learn what's going on
and then drive their own productivity
and then like deep research teams like
where I used to work which was a
nightmare without a central system what
you should set up that kind of system
there and then like my simple guide to
or my simple way of setting up Python
data science projects using like readme
Zin Condor ticket it gets you 90% of the
way there for like having a decent
reputable project thanks for listening
and I'm super happy to answer any
questions you have Thank You Owen for
the presentation and we already have
some questions and so we aren't source
controlling notebooks in my team yet how
good is kid help with this and how do
you make sure things stay reproducible
other than in
and yeah so I mean just yeah use github
notebooks don't play super nice with
with gift there is a tool out there
called what's it called its Envy diff I
think so you can you know it'll it'll
it'll difficult for you you can settle
up with a gift book and stuff so that
I'm you know when you're when you're
like dipping it'll run there's a company
out there that actually add is in hat on
for github and so what happens as pull
requests come in it'll do the diff for
you and like open it'll get it'll put a
URL in the pull request comment and
it'll give you the different front of
you and then you can merge so that gets
you like pretty far and making things
reproduce able so like use Conda or use
docker and then for data tagging so I
have this question here is it possible
to link to use data sets to the shared
analysis this way people could discover
who else has used a data set maybe via
adding a tag for each data set not sure
well I think that's like who has used
the data sets and I think that really
depends on on the type of data you're
looking at you know if I'm doing a
connection string to MongoDB we're
probably not going to be tagging that
like that that actual data connection so
what one thing like I'd recommend is
that like no matter where you have your
data and so like frequently are used to
oiling the pool data directly from
databases or from big shared drives like
EFS on on Amazon or just like Microsoft
Drive in the office and you always want
to have like a Roth data folder and like
your process data folder and just don't
go mixing raw with process which a lot
of people do and it makes not to be mess
yeah question your questions look like
how you manage code version control
versus data version control yeah so I
don't really have amazing answer fee and
data version control
um it's kind of a separate question have
you worked with TV see I guess that's
familiar with it TVC DBC it's like gate
for data and models and stuff yeah so
like we're kind of like well what I'm
proposing here is that you have a
central system for sharing the reports
right not for like necessarily version
controlling data that is like a problem
that you prot you'll probably have to
tackle anyway but again it like if
people's data is so uniquely saying
that's a very that's a very open-ended
question so what I tried to cover there
is really like you know no matter where
your data is you're gonna probably
process it in some way and then present
the results of your processing right if
you're doing like data analysis not if
you're doing like ETL pipe and something
you just sending it off somewhere else
if you're doing analysis you're you're
you're looking at data and generating a
narrative and what I'm trying to cover
here is like you have to share the
narrative that you've got from the data
and like a systematic way
version control of data that's that's a
pretty open question and I'm not sure
like I can give you a great advice there
unless you talk about what this use
cases the specific type of data so Dino
asked if you offer on premises - it
shows now yes we will someday okay
yeah any time yeah I thought it was
envied if yeah the tool is about n be
dine ryujin they're pushed in the put in
the link and if anybody like his trouble
version Kotori notebooks it's super
handy
publishing data so different teams can
benefit from a single report is great
but how do you deal with the problem of
different teams using different
languages for example a previous company
this person fire worked on in the team
to find ROI is fast / revenue another
defined as costs might have a revenue
minus one this is typically solved via
corpus but it's very hard to build on
different languages in terms of
programming languages are different
language in terms of like different you
know algorithms or definitions of
statements used across the company like
data like if you have like Ora ye define
there's something I think there's two of
those are like Kohli bruh that will do
that for you that is again like that's
that's something that maybe it's like
soft company by company it's like
defining your terms having a like a
universal definition in terms of
different languages if you're like so we
like support Jupiter notebooks but also
we just support you know if you have a
project say it's in or or just Python
scripts whatever Jupiter or at sea and
you're doing some analysis and you're
generating results which are typically
graphs you can just you can just use a
readme file and link to the images you
know as you're working and that's like
supported by us as supported by github
also
yet languages is words using a report
that's I think as I get company by
company decision to make about how you
define words across the business I'm not
sure any good system for finding words
across code like checking definitions of
things may be folly whereas what you're
looking for okay
and you've heard the questions I guess
which has a kernel for Jupiter what we
do is we render the Jupiter notebook
itself so it's completely agnostic we
don't actually wrong with notebooks so
we take a notebook that you've generated
on your laptop or on your server you've
pushed it to to get up if you import it
into K so it'll render because it's we
render the Jupiter format so what that's
like doesn't really matter that's
independent from the kernel so you can
use any kernel okay maybe one more
question if there are any it's there's
discussion starting about closer ease
and corpora ok so then let's thank all
one for the talk thanks for having me
and I don't know what happens next
I don't do we have another awkward break